Hello.
>> Hello, Mo.
>> Hello.
>> The Quran, the Islam is trustworthy and
I can prove why
>> you going you going to ask him life? You
going to talk to him?
>> Oh, I thought you was going to kick him.
He He ain't even old enough. He
>> He might give us the best conversation
outside of Muhammad.
>> No, man. He sound
>> Do it.
>> No, bro.
>> Yeah, you do it, man. Man, you soft.
>> You get the best You get the best
conversation out of waiting. little
brother here just waiting till he ain't
saying a word.
>> Would you would you would you trust the
religion with corrupted scripture? Mo,
>> no.
>> Did Allah reveal the Torah, Gospel, and
Psalms?
>> Yes.
>> Did they get corrupted?
>> You quick with it, too.
>> No.
>> The Torah, Gospel, and Psalms did not
get corrupted.
>> No.
>> Awesome. So, that means that the Torah,
Gospel, and Psalms are still intact to
this day. Yeah.
>> Uh, incorrect.
>> I can't do I ain't going to lie, bro.
This can't be four guests in a row, bro.
Come on, bro. What? Muslims, please.
Please stop, bro. Four guests in a row.
What are we What are we doing, man? Is
this a religion or like a a trend?
>> A trend.
>> You know what I mean? Like, what is
>> Thank you so much.
>> Can I Can I ask you guys a question? You
guys are Christian, right? Are you guys
Christian?
>> We're original Quran only Christian, my
brother.
>> Oh, wait. Are you guys Christian?
>> We
>> Yes or no? Yes or no? Are you guys We
are original Christian.
>> We're original Quran only Christians,
bro.
>> Okay. Okay. Now, um, did Jesus die? Did
Jesus die?
>> Activated.
>> Did Wait, did did Jesus die?
>> We can talk about if Jesus died.
>> Yeah, it's activated.
>> No, I'm just asking. I'm just asking.
Answer.
>> I know. I know you're just acting,
little brother, but hold on. Hold on.
Just did Jesus die.
>> Hold on a second, big dog. The first
thing we have to do is solve the first
problem, bro. The first problem is about
the scriptures. Then we can talk about
whether or not Jesus died or not. All
right.
>> Okay. Yes, they're corrupted. I Yeah,
they're they're corrupted.
>> But at first you said
>> they're corrupted in a No, they're
corrupted in another way.
>> And Okay. In what way are they corrupted
>> here? So this for us Muslims, we believe
that this this life is a test. Correct.
>> This life is a test. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So Allah allows people to do really
anything that they're able to do in this
life. If that means corrupting a
religion, but for that they shall be
they shall get sins.
>> Okay.
>> Do you understand?
>> I understand. I understand.
>> So So in Islam
>> Mhm.
>> you are allowed to do anything that you
are able to do in the world in the in
the world. Correct. So when Allah when
Allah like gave them and let them
corrupt it, that's them. And then they
and they get the sins each time. Allah
keeps on going. Keeps on going.
>> Okay, that makes that makes sense.
>> I'm I'm picking I'm picking up what
you're putting down.
>> He makes the Quran the and he says in
the Quran
>> that he'll protect the Quran cannot be
corrupted because he
>> he doesn't say he doesn't say that, but
it's okay.
>> He does say the Quran cannot be
corrupted.
>> All right, no worries. So, so basically
you know human beings have free will
>> and correct the life is a test and so
Allah allows them to enact their free
will as they see fit
>> and if they sin they sin if they do good
they do good
>> and uh it just so happened that some
human beings tampered with his
scriptures and they did not treat it
correctly and so Allah didn't protect
the these previous scriptures but he
decided to protect the Quran
Is that right?
>> Yes. Because the Quran because the Quran
was so powerful.
>> Okay. No worries. So, so Allah decided
to protect the Quran. He didn't he he
didn't protect the previous scriptures.
So, when it comes to the pro the
protection of the scriptures, does Allah
have a good track record of protecting
his scriptures or does he have a bad
track record of protecting his
scriptures?
>> Here, you're you're going to you're I
was listening earlier. You're going to
say the thing about the babysitter and
all the kids and all of that, but as I
told you in the start, Allah was Allah
like saw the Quran, it got so powerful,
he disallowed it to be corrupted. The
first ones were test.
>> I got you. So So does he? Good. So with
that being said, does Allah have a good
track record of protecting his
scriptures or does he have a bad track
record of protecting his scriptures? He
uh he does not uh have a a good record
earlier.
>> And so if the almighty benevolent God
doesn't have a good record of protecting
his scriptures, how could we trust him?
>> I told you why is that? Didn't I tell
you why is that?
>> You said cuz it's a test. You said you
said it's he said it's a test. So we're
still in that test to this day. Right.
>> Exactly. So that means that even as part
of this test, then it's possible that
the Quran could be manipulated and
corrupted. Even if he says that he's
going to protect it, he doesn't have
>> That's the thing. That's the thing. In
all of the other books, Allah never said
that the that they couldn't be
corrupted. In this book,
>> but he does he does say that no one can
change his words, right?
>> He says that in the Quran, nobody could
change his words.
>> He doesn't say in the Quran. He just
says no one can change his words.
Period. He says none among all his
creation can change his words.
>> He said it in the Quran.
>> Yeah. He says in the Quran that nobody
can change his words.
>> When he says when he says nobody could
change his words, he means that you you
still can. But if you do change his
words, it's a sin.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Think about it. Wait,
wait. I'm thinking about it. You're
saying when he says blatantly that no
one can change his words, what he means
is is that people can change his words.
Is that what he really means when he
says no one can do it? He means the
opposite of what he's saying. You got
you got to you got to think about this.
You feel me?
>> If we're being honest and we take the
Quran for what it says. Allah says no
one can change his words. The Torah are
the words of Allah, right? At least they
used to be, right? The the Psalms, the
Gospel, these were all Allah's words at
one point in time, right?
>> Correct.
That means none of them can be changed
cuz none of Allah's words can be
changed. But but if they were changed
then that means that Allah is
untrustworthy and he did not tell the
truth when he said none of his words can
be changed. You you understand my point
>> here? Yeah. That's the thing. When I
tell you that when I tell you that uh
everything that Allah allows anything
not allows he just lets you do anything
that you can do in this world.
>> Does that mean you could also corrupt
his words?
>> You can.
>> So then that means that I can corrupt
the Quran.
>> I mean you can but nobody's going to
catch on with it. People have tried to
corrupt the Quran so much times in the
past but nobody catched on to it.
>> Oh brother, we have so many different
Qurans now because so many people
corrupted it. It's crazy. They try, do
you know, they try to corrupt it. People
in CO 19, they try to make they try to
make a verse about CO 19 that went off
after maybe
>> Have you ever uh
>> Have you ever seen any of my videos
before? Do you know who I am?
>> Not really. No.
>> No. Okay. So, do you watch YouTube a
lot?
>> Uh, I watch Yeah. some YouTube.
>> Okay. So, my channel is God Logic
Apologetics.
>> God Logic. If you look up God Logic on
YouTube, you'll find me. And I did this
video. It's called five Quran variants
that every Christian should know. It's a
short video and what we do here, I got
Arabic speakers with me in that video.
They speak Arabic. One of them is an
ex-Muslim. The sister is an ex-Muslim
with her husband. And what we did was is
we showed five different five
differences in different Qurans that are
really easy to see, easy to share.
Anybody can see these. You should check
out that video. And um
>> Hello.
>> Yeah. And so it's it's called So my
channel is called God Logic.
>> Can I can I ask you a question?
>> Is it based on the subject?
>> Not entirely, but it's based on I have a
question on Christianity
>> in in just a second, brother, cuz we got
to finish this. I need you to understand
the weight of what we're talking about.
It's not just something we can brush
over. If the previous scriptures are
corrupted like you're saying they are
and like all the other Muslims say they
are, then you're literally going against
what Allah says when he says none can
change his words,
>> that means they're sinning.
>> That means they're sinning and that
means that Allah wasn't telling the
truth when he said none can alter his
words. He wasn't he wasn't telling the
truth cuz they obviously can alter his
words. You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But if they do then Allah will
give them this the eternity the eternity
sin.
>> If they do how can that if they if for
example if Allah says no one can change
his words does that mean that people can
change his words? Is Allah telling the
truth when he says that?
>> Yeah. Allah says Allah also wait Allah
also says Allah says Allah also says
that people can't uh people can't go in
relationships before marriage. People
can't drink alcohol.
>> No, he doesn't he doesn't say they can't
do it. He says do not. See I I I think I
see the difference now. You're thinking
of what Allah commands versus what Allah
>> explicitly says cannot be done. So
there's a difference between giving a
command like you're not allowed to do
this, you're not allowed to do that,
you're not allowed to do this. Right?
That's different than saying it's
impossible to do this. It's impossible
to do that. You cannot do this.
>> He said it's impossible.
>> He he doesn't say the word impossible.
What he says is it cannot be done.
Meaning that it is impossible.
>> Can you read me the verse?
>> Yeah. So it says none can no one can
alter the words of Allah.
>> Can you tell me what verse that is?
>> It's chapter 6 verse 115.
Why you turn your camera off? Life
>> on Tik Tok.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't I don't like like like both on
at the same time.
>> You don't you don't like looking at
that?
>> No, cuz the coloring on Tik Tok is like
dark
>> messing up your eyes.
>> No, I don't like how it looks on Tik
Tok. I like my camera here. It looks
really good.
>> Then look at your camera. Don't look at
Tik Tok, but keep your camera on.
>> How am I going to not look at Tik Tok? I
like I'm reading comments, bro. I ain't
talking. I'm reading comments.
>> Look at the comments on the stream. All
right.
>> You hear me?
>> Yes, I can hear you.
>> Okay.
>> I can't hear you anymore if you're off
the app. If you're off the app, I can't
hear you, dude.
>> Oh, okay. So, uh, you said chapter 6,
verse 115.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. I went to my Quran auh
authenticator app that I have and it
says something wholly different.
>> What does it say?
>> I can't here. I could copy it and I
could put it in the chat so you can read
it.
>> Brother, the verse says, "And the word
of your Lord has been fulfilled in truth
and justice. None can alter his words
and he is the hearing, the knowing."
That's what the verse says.
>> The true
>> Yeah.
>> Am I
>> So when you say
>> am I just reading a different Quran or
is this is this Quran corrupted? I think
yeah he does say that none can change
his words what he says.
>> Yep that's what he says. So if none can
change his words that means it's
impossible for his words to be changed.
But if his words were changed then this
verse is a lie. Allah was not telling
the truth.
>> That was verse 615.
>> Yeah.
>> You're here. You're you're correct. But
what's it called? Uh can I ask you a
question?
>> As long as it's on what we just talked
about. What?
>> No. I I was thinking about asking you
another question cuz I'm curious about
something.
>> As long as it's under what we just
talked about, bro. We can't skip over
this.
>> It's something else. It's something
else. Am I allowed to ask you?
>> You can ask me once we finish this. I
promise. Once we finish this, you can
ask me whatever you want. Deal.
>> But I guess it's done.
>> Say that again.
>> I guess I guess it's done.
>> What's done?
>> The the debate.
>> So So you do you see the problem?
>> I know what you mean. I I know what you
mean, but like you got to know what I'm
not fully I'm not fully educated. Like I
just started like I'm educated a lot for
a kid, but like I
>> You are I'm not a counter.
>> You are. That's why I'm having the
conversation with you because you're you
have enough intellect and knowledge to
be able to have a conversation to some
level. That's why I'm not bashing you
or, you know, I'm not pressuring you or
anything like that. I'm just showing you
why we're saying the top that Islam is
untrustworthy. Okay.
>> Now, let me give you what some Muslims
would how they would answer this and
let's work out if that makes sense to
you. Okay. How some Muslims would answer
this is that they'll say, "Oh, well,
this isn't talking about the physical
words of Allah. This is just talking
about his decree that whatever Allah
orders or decrees or promises that that
can't be changed or altered. But the
physical words in the physical book,
they can be changed." That's how that's
how they would uh they would answer
this. Okay. Now, the reason that that
doesn't make sense is because that's not
what it says. It doesn't say that no one
can change Allah's decree. If it said
that, they would have a point. But it
doesn't. It says none can change his
words. Period. When he says something,
it can't be changed. It can't be
altered. It can't be distorted. So, that
would include the Torah, the Psalms, the
Gospel, and the Quran. None of his
revelations, none of his words can be
altered. Right? That would mean that the
Torah, Gospel, Psalms, Quran,
everything, all everything that Allah
has ever revealed is still preserved,
intact, unchanged, and unaltered. That's
what that would have to mean. Make
sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, there's a double problem with that,
too. That because from the Quran
standpoint, the Torah, Psalms, the
Gospel, these books cannot possibly be
changed because they're Allah's words.
That means that what I have is what
Allah revealed. What I have in the Bible
is what Allah revealed and what he sent
down and what the Jews and Christians
were commanded to follow and obey and
believe in in the Muslims.
So that also means that the Quran has a
problem because obviously the Quran
contradicts the Bible, right? Jesus, the
Bible says Jesus is the son of God who
died for our sins. Obviously, the Quran
says no, Jesus is not the son of God.
Allah has no children. He neither
beggets or is begotten. And it was only
made to appear that he was crucified. He
wasn't really crucified, nor did they
kill.
>> Wait. Okay. I have a question then. So
Allah did say that what's it called?
That uh that is that Jesus, right?
People will worship Jesus until now.
Correct.
>> Yeah. He says there something worship
that
>> how I know how would he know that how
would he know what happens in the
future.
>> He's not God.
>> Well, no, no, no. He didn't say until
like now now, but he just says that it
addresses people who worship Jesus.
That's that's Christians were around who
worship Jesus.
>> But Allah also knows what happens in the
future. He also says so much stuff that
happened in the future that come true.
>> Like what?
>> Here.
You know what that cuz that that'll take
you a second to search that we we'll
hold that point cuz that's secondary.
That's not even the main point. I I I'll
I'll leave that alone for now. What I
want you to mainly focus on is the fact
that because the Bible, the Torah,
Psalms, Gospel, the Bible that I have is
intact and preserved from the Quran
standpoint. Then that would mean that
the Quran is false because it
contradicts
the Bible. The Bible is true and
unchanged. That means that Jesus is is
the son of Allah. He is the son of God.
That means that Jesus was crucified for
our sins. And so the Quran would be
wrong for contradicting these books. You
understand what I'm saying?
>> I understand. Okay. So wait, let me go
back to the thing. In the Quran,
Muhammad, what's it called? There's a
verse that says that ma that the people
like the people the people of Qur ones
that were against Muhammad ma they they
said if you're real then show us
something show us show us like one of
your miracles right so what Muhammad did
he got he got his hand what's it called
he he told them okay fine I'll make the
moon I I will make the moon split he
made the moon split this year 2025 Five
pe NASA went up to the went up to the
moon and saw a split in the in in the
moon just like how Allah said, "Bro,
bro, who told you that?"
>> This is in the Quran and it's also a
hadith.
>> No, no, no. Who told you that NASA went
up and saw a split in the moon?
>> They saw I saw in the news they went up
and they saw a split in the moon. You
could search it up.
>> No, look, NASA put out
>> I don't know if it was NASA, but some
>> I can I can I can tell you what NASA
says themsself. NASA put out a statement
because they got so tired of people
saying that the moon was split and
Muslims saying that and going to them
and saying that they're hiding evidence
and stuff. NASA put out an official
statement on their page saying, "No, the
moon was never split. No, there's no
there isn't any evidence that the moon
was split. This never happened." They so
they put that on their official page,
bro.
>> Oh, one second, bro. I'm sorry. My
friend is my Yeah, go on. My friend was
just calling me. I'm sorry. Go on.
>> I was saying that NASA on their own page
put out a statement saying that the moon
was never split cuz they got tired of
Muslims coming to them saying that it
was. So they put out a whole statement
like, "No, the moon was never split. No,
there's no evidence of it ever." That's
what they did, bro.
>> But there's photograph there's a photo
there's photograph of the moon being
split. No,
>> I saw it. Yeah, there is,
>> brother. I don't I don't know who gave
you this picture. I don't know where
what you where you're getting this from,
but this never happened, bro. There's
there's no scientific community, no um
astronomy community that affirms that
the moon was split. None.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Um now, now focus on the
issue because Allah's words can't be
changed. That means that the Bible is
true. You there? I need you to come back
to the screen, man, so I know you're
listening.
>> I'm here. I'm here. I'm here. I'm here.
Keep on talking. I'm here. I'm just
texting. I'm just telling my friend that
I can't call text.
>> Okay. Let let me know when you're done
texting and then I'll uh I'll continue
because this is very important that I
don't want you to get see life.
>> See what
>> you see.
>> You see you see
>> Hello. Hello. Hello. Can you hear me?
>> No. It's a good conversation man.
>> Yeah. So, so with the Quran saying that
none of his words can be corrupted, none
of his words can be altered or changed.
Right. This means that the Bible is
true. And if the Bible is true, you're
off again. Come on, bro. I need you to
pay attention, man. I don't got much
time.
>> I'm here. I'm still here. You're saying,
"And if the Bible is true,
>> if the Bible is true, that means that
the Quran is false if it contradicts the
Bible." Make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> So, because the Bible says that Jesus is
the son of God and that Jesus was
crucified, the Quran contradicts those
two things. It says Jesus is not the son
of Allah
>> and it says he wasn't crucified. That
means that the Quran is false. for
contradicting the true Bible.
>> Okay. Um here I had a nice what's it
called? I had a nice debate. I was just
doing this for a learning experience.
Thank you very much for uh speaking with
me though.
>> Of course.
>> I thought I had some good points.
>> Yeah. God bless you, bro. Keep thinking
about these things. Don't Don't push
them to the side. Really consider and
think about these things. Okay.
Hopefully we talk again someday.
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> You too.
>> Take care, man.
>> See you. You too. Bye.
>> You know the crazy part? It's always the
young one. Ain't that ain't that crazy?
The only ones you get that out of are
the young ones, bro. How do you Muslims
pay attention? How is it that you get,
you know, honest, you know, the
heartfelt conversations out of the young
Muslims? With the adult Muslims, it's
like, you know, too much too much Islam.
>> With the adult Muslims, with the adult
Muslims, you have to talk to them like
they're a kid. With the kids, you can
talk to them like they're an adult.
Dang, that's crazy work. I ain't got I
didn't think about it like that. That's
That's crazy work.
>> With the adult Muslims, we have to talk
to the adult Muslims like they're kids.
With the kids, we can talk to them like
they're a mature adult with some type of
maturity.
>> Insane. But it's so true. Just just
putting it like that is like you you
ain't that's why with with proud Muslim,
right? when I be talking to him, he like
I don't know when I when I first dealt
with Proud Muslim, bro, I said the same
thing. Little dude was on stage the
whole time, bro. And it's like and then
he even brought his partner up.
>> Yep. This is uh this is Matthew chapter
19:14, guys. It says, "Jesus said, "Let
the little children come to me and do
not hinder them, for the kingdom of
heaven belongs to such as these."
Belongs to the children. Why? Because
for example the children they come
innocently. The children they come their
minds are open hearts are open. You come
like a child. The kingdom is yours. The
kingdom is yours. Matter of fact kids
children they run they run to to Christ.
They run to knowledge. Right. Let's see
here verse 13. Then people brought
little children to Jesus for him to
place his hands on them and pray for
them. But the disciples rebuked them.
He's like no don't stop the kids from
coming to me. Jesus said, "Let the
little children come to me and do not
hinder them, for the kingdom of heaven
belongs to such as these." When he had
placed his hands on them, he went from
there. See? sound.